und wenn ich hier draufschlagen dann
zündet sich diese scheiße einfach das
ist so und meine ganzen welt schon
wieder kaputt
hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen zur antwort heute am dienstag
ich habe wieder viel text vorbereitet
die ihr mir per mail an konto auf tt.com
zusenden könnt und zugesendet habt da
habe ich mir vier ausgelegt die
eigentlich alle ganz cool sind also da
kommt mittlerweile wieder coole sachen
an und ich wieder das ganz typische wie
vor jeder folge ich kann nicht dafür
garantieren dass ihr das alles noch
nicht kennt es kann auch sein dass ihr
beim parsen sagt ey com
das kann ich doch schon du arsch daumen
runter erhält also das bitte unterlassen
unterlassen gibt es vor ort hinterlassen
ja klar gibt es wenig behindert
natürlich gibt's das wort also bitte
unter last hieß es sind sachen die immer
lernen noch leute die was davon dazu und
bleibe laut ich kann doch nicht dafür
garantieren dass diese sache noch nicht
in irgend einem anderen video mal
vorgekommen sind weil ich ja nicht alle
videos auf youtube anschauen kann und
deswegen ich stelle die nur die sachen
vor die mir zu gesendet wurden und das
könnt ihr auch tun und die manager oder
beschreibung wir fangen mit dem ersten
effekt von chris und zwar hallo luca ich
habe hier einen kleinen fakt für dich
und zwar ist mir das erst vor kurzem
aufgefallen wenn man im lauf zwei mal
shift also schnieken drückt fängt man an
zu sprinten
ich hoffe dir gefällt der fakt lg chris
tucker nicht christa gedeckt der
christlicher der krise wäre die kugel
perfekt so richtig cool erkenntnis okay
ich drück doppel wo die sprinter
ich mach mal von ihr so doppelvakanz
normal gehen und dann noch mal eben die
ganz normal da geht das nicht aber wenn
ich doppelbrücke dann gehts sondern dann
springe ich halt richtig schnell
wenn ich allerdings nie kinder erkennt
es nickel dann bin ich ja nicht schnell
welche allerdings so ganz normal laufe
und jetzt dabei sneaker und doppel
sneaker dann sprinte ich mache hier in
den 2
ich glaube jetzt mal ganz normale
sneaker und doppelklicken zack und dann
laufe ich ihr könnt ihr selber
ausprobieren wenn ihr denkt dass ich
irgendwie um tricks mit fingern ich kann
jetzt meine finger irgendwie nebenbei
filmen oder so
aber es funktioniert macht einfach mal
dass ihr ganz dass ihr ganz normal geht
es nicht doppelt und dann lauft ihr der
sprinter die richtig schnell
und das sollte jetzt eine richtig geile
sache danke an dich chris die sache
richtig cool so freuen sich wieder beim
geheimnisvollen geräusche an geladen wo
ihr gleich wenn ihr das geräusch gehört
hat am besten ganz ganz schnell die
kommentare schreibt was das denn für ein
geräusch wahr denn jan ist eure chance
größer dass wir in der nächsten folge
erwähnt werden und zwar wurde das letzte
geheimnis soll geräusche erraten von
pascal leidenberger der gewalt hat du
hast ein blatt papier von deinem blog
abgerissen coole folge nehmen einmal
danke an dich pascal s haben wieder
weniger erraten deswegen jetzt mal ein
wenig ein leichteres geräusch und zwar
dass hier was war das wohl von einem
geräusch reiz mir die kommentare und
habe ich sagen jetzt noch viel spaß
weiter bei den fans beim zweiten fake
denken sich wieder alle ruhrkohle tnt l
springt seine welt in die luft voll
witzig und zwar ihr seht schon gespart
hat tnt blog findet beim abbauen soll in
der zitierten tnt blog zündet sich doch
nicht wenn man den erkennt es ganz
normal ich zeig euch hier nochmal wo ist
denn da sind tnt
ich könnte ein tnt gezündet dem es an
zündet das heißt ja das hat ihr dieses
zünden in sich oder wenn ich deine
redstone vernehmen stelle oder ist eben
die paare wenn ich dann erst einmal
drauf habe egal ob in creative oder im
game zu null
kann ich das tnt abbauen das macht ja
gar keinen sinn wenn das dann eben die
kaputtgehen kann man hier nicht abbaut
damals in den älteren versionen ging das
noch hat sich das auch gezündet wenn man
das abort allerdings jetzt muss man das
halt die zünden wenn ich allerdings
diesen befehl eingeben hashtag #tatort
welle leerzeichen wahrzeichen welle 0.1
eindrücklich entartet ist ein tier in
mir drin gespannt naja ok wenn ein
anderes an nebensätze das sieht nicht
sonderlich anders aus allerdings wenn
ich das hier abbau geht es kaputt und
wenn ich hier draufschlagen dann zündet
sich diese scheiße einfach das ist so
und meine ganzen welt schon wieder
kaputt
das ist auf jeden fall eine sache die es
im märz
krass da könnt ihr tnt quasi spawnen bei
ihnen jemanden ins haus und er kriegt es
nicht weg wenn ihr das macht auf einem
server oder so wenn die admin rechte
habt dann könnt ihr das einfach ich
mache meine ganze welt blickt wieder
kaputt dann könnt ihr das einfach so
machen und er kann es sich abbauen er
wenn er es abbau zündete sich und zündet
dnt kann man nicht wegmachen
er könnte höchstens obsidian darum bauen
und es dann zünden weil obsidian geht
nicht kaputt aber ich habe eine welt
kaputt gemacht übrigens meine welt so
ein bisschen neuer gemacht ich finde es
sieht jetzt irgendwie schöner aus mit
diesen zeilen und geil also echten cool
effect von alex ich räume auf ich räume
auf ich räume ich räume ich räume
auflädt ihre ganze behind the fact the
behind the scenes bei den fans folgen
das ist so viel dass es viel mehr behind
the scenes als man das irgendwie auch
normal wie du nimmst einfach aus aber
bei den 14 jahre lang suchen dann geh
wieder die halbe welt dabei kaputt und
hdds effekt würde mir zugesendet von tom
luca danke an dich cooler name übrigens
sieg oder zweiten name warum es nicht an
erster name egal kommen und zwar wir
sehen hier endet und weekend ich bin im
game mode 0 die schweizer in japan und
der der sagt mir genau dann wo das endet
das heißt die kritik nach das war jetzt
auf jeden fall super wulff jedenfalls
kann ich dadurch hier so ein bisschen
mich rum teleportieren der erkenntnis an
einer perle nicht viel geändert und ich
stehe dahinter meiner kiste
wenn ich allerdings in den game ort
einst gehe in den creative mode geht
nicht geht mich ihr seht jemandem aus
ich drücke ich käme diese taste und es
geht nichts ich kann hier quasi dieses
dieser perle nicht verwenden wenn ich im
creative mode bin das heißt im creative
ort kann ich wenig porten das ist ganz
einfach irgendwie wahrscheinlich so
gedacht so ja wenn du könntest baut muss
wieso musst du dich deine antworten du
kannst dir einfach rumfliegen oder so es
funktioniert auf jeden fall nicht im
creative gesehen und das wachs ein
bisschen rum
währenddessen wenn ich im game mode 0
bin könnte ich nicht die ganze drum
teleportieren und wird zwangsläufig
irgendwann sterben aber auf jeden fall
dank an dich tom luca für den richtig
grün verlässt effekt kommt von comics
und zwar sagt er bzw paul oder
bayern-fan 31 keiner
jetzt nennen soll darstellen viel zu
viele namen bei deiner mail fledermäuse
droppen auch keine ep ich habe ja in der
letzten folge gesagt das will ja keine
ipi droppen also keine erfahrung
allerdings machen fledermäuse dies auch
nicht ich hab mir so einen tollen glas
kaltes eingebaut der sieht von außen
relativ steif auch wenn ich allerdings
reingehe ist mit direkt eine fledermaus
nach draußen entwischt sogar zwei aber
von hier sieht das ganze sonst wären wir
nicht in den glascontainer ist
eigentlich ganz cool mit diesem sheik
ich töte zum beispiel eine fledermaus
und also ich kann er erst mal im
creative mord bleiben da seht ihr da
dürfen keine punkte
wenn ich auch den game und null geht ich
habe keine erfahrung habe extra in der
folge gerade extra bei dem fag dafür
gestorben natürlich extra dafür wenn ich
jetzt mal eine tüte wenn er eine sterben
würde ihr hört es die stellen die ganze
zeit glocken auch keine erfahrung das
ist das schwert ist egal
ich kann auch jemand sein jammern
schwert nehmen das ist relativ egal die
gruppen keine erfahrungen egal womit ich
die box womit ich die töte ich sammle
keine erfahrung dazu das ist vollkommen
egal ob ich das eben mit einem schwert
mache oder mit einem bogen wenn man
überhaupt ein fehler mit einem bogen
töten könnte weil ja irgendwie so
beweglich sind
es geht auf jeden fall alles nicht es
geht wieder im game und 1 das kann ja
nochmal zeigen wenn ich jetzt mal eine
tüte die ihr gerade so flatternd
herumflattern war ja jetzt hier du
arschloch sei die drop nix möchte hier
irgendwie mit einem golfstaat wird oder
so seht ihr ebenfalls bleibt stehen
erstmal das seht ihr mich zuerst dass
die nicht stehen bleibt für mich du
kleinster viel soll dies auch nicht
gesteuert sowie ist gestorben aber die
drop keine erfahrung und das auf jeden
fall nicht coole sache danke an dich
paul dass du mir das gesagt hast und die
sonne geht unter nicht sagen das war's
auch schon wieder mit dieser folge wenn
es euch gefallen hat zeigt mit einem mag
ich habe jetzt in zwei finals am start
wie gefallen euch die zeit oder mit
einer bewertung schreibt perfekt
entweder die kommentare oder per mail an
contact aber dann kommt oder wir sagen
sehen wir uns morgen bei calida oder in
einem anderen video wenn ihr ihn los
video von mir anschaute